foreign
[Music]
my name is Liz Pauline I'm a postdoc at
said logic lab in the human genome
sequencing Center the Baylor College
medicine and today I will talk about
nipples 2 and how it enables population
uh structural variation comprehensive
population variation detection from
mosaics to population level
let's start
over the past decade
the role and impact of structural
variants have become more and more
relevant
circular variants are Loosely defined as
50 paper or larger genomic alterations
that fall into five categories deletions
insertions duplications inversions and
translocations
in some cases Complex events that are
combination of two or more of these
types
here we can see examples of each of them
for example in the case of deletion our
sequence will have a meeting uh part
that is present in the reference on the
other side for insertions or sequence
will have additional information that is
missing in the reference
for the case of duplication a portion of
the sequence will be duplicated either
in tandem so that means next to each
other or they will have some other
unique sequence in between for the case
of Industry duplications
for the case of inversion the sequence
is not changed but some part will be in
an inverted orientation when we compare
it to the reference
and finally for translocation
part of the sequence will map to a
portion or one chromosome of the
reference while an other part will map
to another chromosome of the reference
now despite that single nucleus polymer
systems are in a range of four to five
million for Human Genome the structure
of virus impact the most number of
nucleotides in the genome and account
for the greatest cause of diversity
given their size
in recent years there have been an
increased evidence about their
importance across all categories of life
for example they have important roles in
the position causing the disputation
defense
structural Barons also have a great
impact in human disease from mendelian
disorders where deletions or
duplications of genetic regions have an
association with multiple syndromes
also neurological diseases we repeat
expansions are associated with
Parkinson's and Huntington disease
after the case of cancer duplication of
oncogenes which lead to overexpression
our sincerity breast cancer
these can be very complex as we see in
this example of a breast cancer cell
line
also and connect with the previous
example
they have an uh
they have an impact on gene expression
what it can lead to the disruption of
shin function or a modification of Gene
dosage
currently our group is working alongside
the GTX Consortium to further and build
impact of structure of variant engine
regulation
finally they have an impact on phenotype
across humans and all organisms
where including structure bearings as a
source of variation helps to better
explain heritability of certain traits
despite
interference
[Music]
to study because single nuclear
transpiration
it's more uh easy to discover
and given that
our understanding of how we study
structural violence has been driven by
technological advances
but from the 1940s and 1980s did the
genetics and keratopin was the main way
to other structural variation
here we could only detect large
variations such as terms and
duplications or chromosome armed gains
and losses
then
reversing technology we were able to
have a better resolution on these
translocation events
neck following microarray data gave us
access to Gene gains and losses
finally we short and wrote longer
sequencing we're not able to detect more
structured burners
however Illumina sequencing is not able
to easily identify this event
but it detects roughly within 10 12 000
structural variants per human genome
on the other hand
with laundry technology we're able to
detect twice the number of structural
variants per genome but not only the
number is important
as long brick technology gives us access
to difficult genomic regions
as you're able to detect previously
inaccessible structural apparents in
medical relevant genes
that cannot be accessed with shortlisted
Traders
hyderability sequences which also
include centromere and the telomere
with both Oxford Nano board and back bio
improving the sequence quality and soon
reaching levels of illumina-like errors
along the genome learn rig technology is
no longer a novelty and population and
production scale studies in our reality
we can see here that back bio High key
has improved accuracy with a drawback of
the REITs nothing too long
falling behind inaccuracy
but reaching read length in the hundreds
of KB
with their Ultra lamp technology
here we can show you in a red line the
what Illumina advertise as the maximum
error rate and we can see that black bio
has already achieved Illumina light
error rate
while ont is still falling behind
but how do we detect structural variants
with long brick technology
so here five examples one for each of
the structural variant types
so for deletions we will have a split
feed meaning that or initial sequence
I will split in two because there's a
missing part uh that is present in the
reference that is not present in your
sample next for duplications we will
have a increased coverage a different
portions of a given read can be aligned
to the same sequence
next four inversions if the rate is long
enough we'll see part of it is in
inverted orientation compared to the
other other two
next for insertions we also get a split
read but in this case a part of it will
not map to the reference as the sequence
is missing
next for translocations
one part of the read will be mapping to
a c chromosome
while they all the part of the read will
be to analyze the three chromosome
given the importance of circular
variants we're still struggling to
detect germline or even robustly
identify the normal structure of
violence
so it is here that we introduce nipples
to our design of the popular SD color
nipples
so first it needs to improves on
germline SC calling being more accurate
and faster than currently popular
methods
but we didn't stop there and we enabled
new applications in the realm of
structural variant calling
first by solving the problem of
population scale structure variant with
long brick technology
and second by enabling the detection of
low frequency structure apparents across
data sets
these low frequency SPS are also called
as non-germline somatic or multicast
phase
so first in order to test nipples to
Improvement on German calling we make
use of the two genomial bottle benchmark
datasets
these data sets are a structured variant
root data set that will compile by
manual duration using using multiple
sequencing Technologies
we use this Benchmark datasets to First
assess the performance of simplest two
and second to compare sniffles 2 to
other available tools including nipples
1.
the First Data that we use is a genome
one benchmark
identification of large insertions and
deletions
the second one is a characterization of
challenging medical relevant genes that
are not accessible for sure read data
because they are too complex includes
higher repetitive sequences and
segmental duplications
as a metric we're going to use the F1
score which combines precision and
recall in a single metric
here we're using the genotype F1 score
which not only takes into account the
presence or absence of the structural
variant but also its genotype
we can show you here with the blue arrow
the performance of Sniffles to involves
as one genotype and CPU time as you can
see the snipple 2 has the highest
performance with uh compared to all
methods that are here shown
one
here this V PV has been entered the name
so first we can show you uh that we made
the comparisons with different coverages
from 50 to 5X and one thing that goes uh
thought is that at low coverage many of
these are cannot even compete with
Netflix 2. this is the California we
have an automatic or adversar selection
for filtering structure of virus
candidates based on available coverage
in contrast for other SV callers they
rely on manual adjustments of these
parameters to retrieve acceptable
results across coverages and in some
cases even for sequencing technology
so what we did next is to give them a
chance to compete with neighbors 2 is we
optimize the parameters for these other
colors
as we have shown that with the full
parameters people strongly outperforms
them at low and medium coverages
but we uh but then with optimized
parameters we give them a chance to
improve their uh both accuracy and speed
as you can see on the right hand side
all tools have improved uh
have improve accuracy
when we optimize these parameters but
none of them come close to nipples too
which Remains the most accurate and
fastest of them all
next we go to the challenging medical
dreams in this case uh the results as
you can see for the uh in both the F1
genotype and speed this nipple 2 is
better than all other available tools
when we compare the accuracy and speeds
of snipples 2 against the other tools we
can see that if we take the second best
which in this case is student V
for these results qsv took almost 10
times the time in in CPU time
in the other hand if we take the second
fastest one which is svim
the result of the people's 2 is 12 more
accurate
and thought
we show that people too is more accurate
and also the fastest of all current uh
tools available for structure buying uh
calling
so next
we have shown you first now that uh
structure uh before 2 has
is now the best in general SD calling so
now we go uh for a different uh approach
and we perform new applications in the
random structure environment calling
in this case uh a recent review by your
uh
by a group has shown that the number of
individual sequence in uh in with
long-range technology is rapidly growing
in just in the past three years
we went from 10 in 10 12 uh like in the
10th numbers of circular certain
individuals uh sequence with longer
technology to the thousands
and future studies aim to reach 1
million uh individuals sequenced with
Oxford nanopore technology
for this reason we have implemented in
sniffles 2 a population wall
which will allow us to have a full SD
genotype from family Trio to populations
current pipelines are slow as they
require multiple steps
here we show you an example with
security
so the first step for both currency and
Surface 2 is to call structural variant
for each of the individuals in the
population in this case for this example
we have a family Trio mother father and
problems
the second step for qsb will be a merge
of the structural variants that were
called for these three individuals next
we will know a region of typing steps
which will require to read the alignment
files again
this step is very slow
after this long step we'll do a next
another merge in order to get a fully
genotyped population BCF file
in contrast first nipple suit there's a
single emerging step as we have created
a special binary file that contains the
structure buying candidates which are
then used for the merging step without
the needs of raising the alignment file
again
avoiding this significantly decreases
the runtime and those were able to
produce a fully genotype BTF file much
faster
for this same example this need for two
took only 65 CPU sections with meaning
that we are 2010 faster than current
method
but not only that nipples 2 also solves
the M plus one problem
as we can add new uh samples very easily
with previous pipelines you we will need
to perform all the merging Regional
typing remerging steps for each sample
that is added but not for the cases
table two we just need to add the new
samples to the merging step
finally we'll show you that we can scale
up this to a population level by
performing a merge of over 1 000 samples
so first we assess nipples to population
merge using the he-002 family tree by
color structure of variants from the
model father and problem and then
performing the merge in order to obtain
a fully genotype DCF file
here what we measure are the mendelian
error meaning consistent genotypes are
those that can be explained by medinaire
those that are inconsistent are cases
that violate mendelian inheritance
and those that are meeting our cases in
which the tools could not assess the
genotype of a specific structure
environment
we can show you here with the blue arrow
that nipples too has a high number of
mendelian concordant genotypes a low
number
of non-concordant genotypes in an
negligible number of incomplete
genotypes
when we compare these results to Purity
and a simple merge in the middle we can
see that there's an increase in the
number of incomplete genotypes
then if we perform the force call and
the original typing and re-emerging
we can obtain that these results improve
however not at the point of Neighbors 2.
as as these results from Q to V have a
lower number of important genotypes
higher number of non-convertent
genotypes and a higher number of Music
genotypes
or stresses we perform the merging of
1002 genomes which means it was 334
family trios
this endeavor took nipples to 9.25 CPU
hours which means that we are four times
faster at merging 1000 genomes that it
is for students V to perform a family
Trio
so next we apply
the population merge uh to of level 2 to
a data set of 31 samples that contains
seven full families meaning modern
father and problems
with known disease status
nipples to population mesh was able to
attack
the structure of variants that are
disease relevant that affect the
magnitude in locals
these little neurological and
developmental disorders primarily in
males
as many of these structural variants are
inherited from the model
in this first
example that we show you
it's a duplication that's coupled with
an inversion so on the left hand side
it's the first of the two duplications
that we can see and that one affected
the magnitude Gene logos
the second one on the right hand side is
near the max P2 Gene logos and it's also
duplication
when we apply uh equals two we can
observe that there were also two
inversions that affected both the
duplications
and in the last part we need we show you
the reads that connects these these
inversions that were detected by
simplest two
so next we will show you an even more uh
difficult uh
structural balance to call
this is a very complex event that
combines multiple of the structural
variants so the first one a it's a
duplication
this was obtained with array data
second in B it's a duplication
and the third one is C is again another
duplication
so a second tracker you can see is the
rate data in which the black dots means
that it's like regular coverage
then the log ratio goes to one because
it means that double the alleles here so
we have a duplication in a as you can
see there's missing part between the
duplication the duplication this is
because there is a segmental duplication
here
marked in gold and this here the array
cannot assess data
next with nipples 2 we're able to take
an inversion and the first duplication
shown here in green
and all of these affected magnitude in
locals
beneath we show you
the split reads that were we used to
identify this inversion those are colors
in pink and blue
finally you can see then that many uh uh
there are kind of gray reeds in beneath
and there are some that are white
those are showing the segmental
duplications
so in this case nipples 2 was only able
to detect one of the two Junctions
because the other one Falls within the
segmental duplication and thus it's very
hard to detect them
so we can show you here that sniffles 2
is a grade 8 in order to detect these
very Complex events
the last part we can show you how this
is linearized meaning how this is all
connected in the genome
as you can see it is very Complex events
not only need one single technology but
multiple ones and here we can show you
the symbols too it's able to Aid greatly
in the detection of structure of Art
so finally for another application
we turn to low frequency structural
violence
and so we have implemented in sniffles 2
and non-germline mode
multiple solids have shown that low
frequency structure of variants also
known as somatic or multi cases are
likely causal across neurological
disorders and oral diseases such as
cancer
but how does this work
so first here we show you a benchmark
data set
this dataset is 70x coverage
and contains mostly reads from the model
so we have here created these Benchmark
benefits with reads from the model and
as on
most of the risk comes from the motor
and we have spike in various
concentrations of the Sun
both individuals share genetic
background however there will be
differences and these differences will
be some structural variants
here you can see most of the reason not
show any signal of the structure
environment but three of The Roots shown
in purple
these three are insertions that were
called by three plus two
and when we compare the results of
equals two to the genome in a bottle
called standard we can see that these
insertions are actually two positives
so next so if we apply the default mode
of Staples 2 we cannot observe anything
so here we show you
the titration of these uh
reads from the Sun from the mother and
the sun which are 60x 65x for the modern
FFX from the Sun in the first sample
next 63 to 7 60 to 10 and 55 to 15.
we can show you here in the first lot
for example in this 65 to 5. for this
case scenario many of the reads that are
contain the structure Baron are in the
range of one or zero meaning that we
it's very hard to detect them with a
single breed
still we were able to detect
and 35 percent of them
just increasing a bit the sequencing
depth of this specs in events
a huge increase in the record
and this is done without affecting the
Precision of FS2
The Gray Line will represent here it's a
force called meaning that we give
examples to the information where the
structural variants are present so you
just need to call them
when we compare uh the final dot on the
top
which means that we have 20 percent
roughly uh information from these low
frequency structure environment the
result is mostly it's almost comparable
to a force call
so in the grade line the information is
already known but in the Orange Line the
information is not known
and thus showing how good is nipples 2
at locating these low frequency
structural variants
so we apply this
to a long read data set of 50x coverage
of a regional operate sample
this sample is from an individual that
has a rare neurodegenerative disorder
called MSA
this disorder has Progressive autonomic
dysfunction and parkinson-like symptoms
here we show you on the right side the
actual data this is not an example
so here all most of these streets do not
contain any information regarding uh the
presence of a structure Baron for three
of them
here sniffles 2 with the non-general
mode was able to capture a rare
structural variant that was made both by
Illumina at 90x coverage and by Optical
mapping with bio Nano at roughly 700x
coverage
you can see here uh that this is a
division
and this deletion
is in a repetitive sequence
in a gene that is important for MSA
disease progression
and thus showing that sniffles 2 is able
to recover these rare events that are
this is relevant
in summary
we have shown you the sniffles 2 has
increased accuracy across establishment
benchmarks
and it strongly decreases the
computational cost as it is the fastest
of the available tools
then
we presented you new applications first
population scale structure by calling
and we apply these to a data set and
detected the role of structural variant
affecting the magnitude Gene logos in
middle and disorders
then with the detection of low frequency
structure of variant we show you that
simple 2 is able to detectomatic SVS in
neurodegenerative disorders
nipple 2 is available as a conduct
package and the preparing was released
in every April
now I will say I would like to thank
everyone involved in this project first
the satellite check lab
especially
more smoker who is the main developer's
nipple soup
and also all collaborators Claudia
Carvalho from the pnri
and crystals Pro cookies from the UCL
and you for your attention thank you